AND HIS 1,000 ROUGH RIDERS
GO TO CUBA.
THE TRANSPORT SHIP
ISN'T BIG ENOUGH.
300 GUYS HAVE TO STAY BEHIND.
EVERY OTHER GUY HAD
TO LEAVE HIS HORSE BEHIND.
SO THESE GUYS LAND IN CUBA,
AND THEY GET AMBUSHED.
THEY'RE IN A VALLEY
BETWEEN TWO HILLS
WHERE THE SPANISH
HAVE THE UPPER HAND.
THEY'RE SITTING DUCKS.
TEDDY ROOSEVELT'S MEN
START TAKING FIRE.
HE LOSES OVER 200 OF HIS MEN
IN THIS 20 MINUTES.
TEDDY ROOSEVELT RIDES UP
TO THE SECOND-IN-COMMAND
OF THE REGULAR ARMY,
AND HE SAYS,
WE'RE GETTING OUR ASSES KICKED
RIGHT NOW.
THE ONLY WAY
WE'RE GONNA SURVIVE
IS IF WE CHARGE
UP THIS HILL.
AND THE SECOND-IN-COMMAND
OF THE REGULAR ARMY SAYS,
THE COLONEL ISN'T HERE
TO MAKE THAT CALL.
I CAN'T LET YOU DO THAT.
AND TEDDY ROOSEVELT SAYS,
I AM A COLONEL.
IT'S MY CALL NOW.
HE RIDES,
UNAFRAID OF BULLETS,
TO THE FRONT LINES.
HERE, TEDDY ROOSEVELT
IS HERE.
HIS HISTORY AND HIS PEOPLE
ARE STANDING BEHIND HIM.
HE SAYS, I'M GONNA GO.
I'M GOING UP THIS HILL.
AND I'M GONNA--
AND I'M GONNA DEFEAT
THESE SPANISH FORCES.
FOLLOW ME.
AND IF YOU TURN AROUND,
I WILL SHOOT YOU.
SO TEDDY ROOSEVELT
LED THIS CHARGE
AND ALL OF THE PEOPLE FOLLOWED
TEDDY ROOSEVELT UP THE HILL.
THEY BEAT BACK
THE SPANISH FORCES.
AND THE SPANISH FORCES
RETREATED,
BUT TEDDY ROOSEVELT
KEPT CHARGING,
AND WITHIN TWO WEEKS,
SPAIN SURRENDERED.
WHEN HE WAS 11 YEARS OLD,
TEDDY ROOSEVELT SAID,
IF I'M GONNA BE ANYTHING,
THE THING THAT I'M GONNA BE
IS A BADASS.
AND THAT DAY, HE FULFILLED
THAT PROMISE TO HIS YOUNG SELF,
AND HE BECAME
A [bleep] ROCK STAR.
[triumphant music]
♪